that's it check it out  i saw all your hard drives and guess  what  you're not a photographer and you  definitely can't fit into a size two  there man you're on facebook why you  been telling people you're not on  facebook  people want to be your friend man  all right and you this guy you're the  one who told the press you wrote an  email to the editor i saw it and i also  saw a quicktime movie of your little  printer fire test on your hard drive  this guy's a snitch he's the snitch so  that's it check it out  can i fill out an application oh  absolutely here take a seat  i should let you know right away this is  just an entry-level job uh it's really  basic we're looking for like a  self-starter as someone who can meet  deadlines and just pretty much just go  the extra mile i guess i can do that  great and uh obviously we're looking for  someone who knows photoshop and  dreamweaver uh corel painter illustrator  after effects all the basics  i don't know any of those